australia wants to regulate facebook
in return it's got a news blackout
facebook scrubbed its news feed
wiping information from health pages
government agencies
welfare networks and weather warnings
the government wants to bring in a law
that forces facebook and google to pay
media outlets
when they republish their content google
has conceded
signing deals with several media outlets
but facebook has not
facebook was wrong facebook
its actions were unnecessary they were
heavy-handed
and they will damage its reputation here
in australia facebook announced the move
on its blog
saying australia misunderstands the
relationship between itself and
publishers
it says publishers willingly choose to
post news on facebook
to sell more subscriptions grow their
audiences and
increase advertising revenue it
estimates it generated more than 5
billion free referrals to australian
publishers
worth an estimated 315 million dollars
last year
the government and facebook ceo mark
zuckerberg
talked again on thursday the principle
is very clear
we google and facebook are important
parts of the
digital ecosystem in australia they're
important parts of the economy we've
made it clear
that we want them to continue operating
here but we've also made it clear that
if you do business in australia
you need to comply with the law of land
in australia many in the media agree
arguing tech giants must pay for the
journalism they republish
well of course news organizations use
whatever platform they can to share
their content the problem is that what
this has meant
is google and facebook now take the
line's share of advertising revenue
which makes it
very difficult for media companies to
employ
the journalists our members that need to
bring quality
news human rights watch also condemned
the move
saying facebook has cut off more than
the media
vulnerable australians are the ones
caught in the middle here because
whilst this law is aimed at news
companies there are a whole range of
community organizations who've been
affected
australia has given google and facebook
two options
strike deals with media companies or
have fees
set for them but facebook has decided on
a third
take away its news feed all together
charlotte ballas
al jazeera